when I first started I did this Mark
Wahlberg character yeah and I would do
that I just talk like this all the time
I'm like how you doing you're doing good
what's going on you guys should have
Donnie in here sometime help me
straighten them up
hello everyone hola Mis Amigos you're
listening to oh my God
hola with me
they're not gonna go to that dry cleaner
right here by Kim Phelps
you know George is oh I'm sure he's
around here somewhere what's his name
George Lopez George Lopez oh my God OMG
oh my God
he built part of my town
he did huh yeah that [__] was
the Ice Cold Man oh my God wasn't he
yeah so he was talking about high school
they looked for those kids in my
hometown he was the guy that said did
they arrest anybody else to throw it in
the air that there was more than one
person really yep John Wayne Gacy did
that wow just because you know now you
can I mean he's like a psychological man
yeah
uh Daniel Van Kirk I'm here from the
great state of Illinois I am Rochelle
Rochelle is that where the is that where
the peaches are from
no we just got corn corn and soybeans
Rochelle Illinois yeah yeah that's what
was my first job uh did you
I probably could I probably could be
killed for this but did you know that
Monsanto makes the seeds that the
farmers have to use
no and yes and they have guys that go
around in cars that like men in black
and if they go to your farm and you are
not using the said seed
that you will be they'll shut you down
fine and shut down maybe maybe I'm wrong
but I I think that there's in the
farming there's a uh Monopoly in this
thing where you're not allowed if you're
a farmer you're a farmer for
the country
so they own you
that's why you see corn with testicles
that's why I never went to the piscas
you know about that you never did it I
never wanted to go brother Matt did you
you worked out there yeah it's my first
like my first job was detasseling corn
oh you like pull out the stocks yeah
it's absolutely Melrose to the female
Rose and you'd pull out like every
fourth you'd four rows and then one row
off I don't okay six a.m in the morning
you know that no I didn't know there
were female welcome Mexican just put
mayonnaise in your [__] trips over
you'd have to walk through these fields
you start doing here like 12 13. you
start at like 6 a.m and everybody did it
nobody said everybody I mean a couple
kids didn't but for some like where I
grew up you'd be like what's wrong with
you why don't you want a tassel corn
because everybody did it what's wrong
with you yeah and then oh you get so hot
you're covered in mud by the end of the
day until I worked for a place called
Coppell farms and they had these
machines you'd ride in and everybody all
these kids are just being these little
baskets and you'd be pulling out the top
of these is that the one they're wearing
over Jeremy no no different different
um but yeah that was in a [__] driver
I forgot because he tried to help them
so so you're just up there and it's just
you got to pull the tassels out of all
the tops of all these Corners
at the end of the day when the sun's
going down probably [__] beautiful
huh gorgeous but when you're out there
hey let me ask a question there you go
he's gonna make fun of me I know that's
okay what is a tassel it's the it's the
top it's the top of the Corn that I
think man I haven't done this in so long
it's uh it's how the how they can be
like uh fertilized like what what how
they end up growing like I think they're
all both male and female until you pull
out the tassel and then it's a it's the
way that it grows so you would have one
male and then you'd have four rows of
female and then another Mound somebody's
probably well you're an idiot I'm like
well I did it and I was 13. it's not
like they explained everything to me but
um you'd pull them all out and you'd
have to pull them one after the other
and then that's that's how they would
Harvest that four throw they would never
Harvest but then everything in between
for the sweet corn or feed or stuff like
that but then I got elevated up to bail
and hay and that is the hardest best job
I've ever had in my life oh man so I did
you know they were male and female corn
no no I never heard of that I mean
you're saying it wrong you had no you
didn't know it either yeah no if it
wasn't me I would pull the fourth row
and leave the other one [__] he just
[__] uh uh took away the whole yeah
because and it stays that way right they
stayed yeah wow yeah yeah I had also I
was a Gravedigger in my hometown too I
had all sorts of weird jobs growing up I
didn't do it for very long one summer
and I'm like I'm done I'm done taking
grapes
legally not the type of thing
Machinery you know you use a backhoe but
you still need someone to get in there
especially when you fill it back in so
I'd be standing on somebody's casket and
you're up you know the ground up about
here and you would be bringing in the
first like two three inches and then you
have to stamp it down so that it settles
correctly and I'm pounding on this dead
dude's casket I can still see his family
driving away
small town too because everybody you've
ever known that's passed away is in this
Cemetery too my grandpa's in there
kidding went to high school with died in
a farming accident like everybody it was
depressing as hell when they dig the
hole in the bottom you you get it just a
level yeah
yeah exactly yes uh but so you stomp it
and then it gets but you don't have a
level like no no they just need a layer
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah but
at the first time I got in well did you
you guys ever have to exhume anybody
I never did there were bodies of zoom
while I was working in the bureau but I
never exhumed one time we had to we had
to pull somebody out and then open it of
course the key didn't work and so we had
to like hack saw the hinge to drag it
off oh and the guy started hacksawing
like into the so that it didn't work
because uh the it had been so long I
don't even know why they don't tell us
why they were pulling this person out
but they dug them out that that's that
smell what if they were just boarding
they're like hey [__] let's
who do you like we want to know what was
wild but wait a minute so so so they put
the key in there it doesn't really work
in [__] years go by right and of
course it doesn't I knew I knew it
wouldn't work and what did the casket
look like let's do like pretty much the
same okay yeah yeah because it's like
it's not steel whatever it is but it's
like it was intact it didn't look it
looked dirty it wasn't like weathered
away they put the concrete over no it's
all no there's no it's just a coffin
yeah wow and then uh we they the guy we
were with was hacksawing the hinge to be
able to get it open and went into like
the court that smells one of the worst
and he opened it up and you know yeah
you you anybody who goes I don't know if
I've ever smelled a dead body you'll
never forget it yeah you'll and you'll
know if you're smelling something that
is sure that rancid that you're like
that's what does it smell like like if
you and your old lady are dancing all
weekend no no
you can't remember put them together in
your clothes it gets in your clothes too
[__] I don't know get in the clothes
dude you're old enough
remember you throw garbage in the
garbage cans and there'd be maggots down
there yeah and you'd open it up and you
smell that's what it smells like
bitterly
much much larger scale much worse it was
terrible maggots that they just appeared
my cousin's a fireman where do they come
he's a fire in my own time
Flags yeah but they had so he they had a
uh semi as a truck stop outside of my
town and sometimes these guys will have
heart attacks oh they won't find them if
for days and days until eventually ugly
until eventually someone called well
this is where we think they're you know
a lot of times now with GPS they know
while this car they haven't driven in
eight hours they're supposed to have
left six hours ago but um this was still
not connected to a dispatcher that's the
way they go out here because they're
just and they were driving to show up
Midwest you know Midwest 90 degrees 100
humidity and my cousin said there's just
maggots and I asked him I go where he
goes and it doesn't matter what the room
is or where someone is after a few days
are this big they're going oh thank God
for him
I can remember we uh had permission pick
a guy up up in the mountains normally
had to wait for the corners off we were
losing light they said get him I had
some people from emergency services with
me so we had to get this guy to put him
in a body bag and he was so gone I
remember trying to get him in the body
bag and hair and scalp and just
everything's coming up yep so for some
reason
I ended up as they're pulling them up I
ended up on the bottom so juices were
coming out no yeah that's what it was
like in the semi cab too I got up on the
car I we got we got him up to the car
the guys that were up there made me ride
on the hood of the car wouldn't even let
me in the car really I rode on the hood
until we got down to uh open space we
got him off
threw him in a helicopter
and we took off we went from Angeles
Crest we landed over here at the uh
coroner's office they got the body
fortunately I left my my cop car there
yeah I got out put plastic on my seats
and then I had a clean suit
right out of the cleaners in the back so
it drove straight to East LA station I'm
walking in with new set of clothes and
they're seeing me there's a hey Gil
what's going oh as they got close oh
so I just got in there showered got
those clothes through them in a plastic
bag took them to the cleaners I knew the
cleaner guy said vic if you can clean
them do it if not throw them away yep
because they were they were that bad and
anything that I had touched inside the
file was paperwork skunk forever never
got the smell out of whatever but what
is it's in the air right it is in your
clothes you think that a necrophiliac
would get us a [__] straw like a
juice box and suck all the juices I have
no idea what he would do Aaron
I mean no no I'm sure you've covered it
but that's the whole thing with the
Dahmer deal which I have a big issue
with that show but that's the whole
thing with Domino she was smelling his
neighbor was smelling that stuff all day
every day every day and it's and it was
in her place too there's no way it
wasn't in her place I mean like Ian okay
so so now describing that
um you see what was going on in that one
apartment building right and the lady
they have calls right they have and she
said hey this [__] stuff right here
she she tried the most
and
you probably can't move anywhere you
[__] you don't you're just making
ends meet
man
um during the summer I went to that I
went to that apartment you know when you
remember were you doing a show Milwaukee
hey Milwaukee I landed and then I was
doing the comedy cafe or some [__]
out there uh where they saw me airfare
they do they got a good new one the
laughing test
and I told the dude we land in the
airport I go Hey where's Dahmer's
apartment and he's like what you don't
want to see that [__] that's it back
because they're gonna tear it down I
said come on dude went to the Chocolate
Factory and went but [__] you know
when you're a [__] only child and
Latino and every only time you guys talk
is guess who died yeah of course you're
gonna do that [__] you know my
grandmother never talked to me she'd be
able to sit down after guess who died
whatever [__] I've been home for [__]
eight hours this is what you finally say
guess who's died you know it's also one
of those hotels there too in one of
those rooms he killed somebody too oh
yeah yeah and they tried to say you know
they don't tell you which one it is but
case we were talking before we started
Gacy built one of the little shopping
areas in my hometown so after he got
caught they had one of those seismic
readers or whatever they can through
cement look for something they were well
thank God they didn't find any but he
but that was that was in my hometown too
and you know that's the next one they're
gonna make yeah it makes I hate it so
much like your guys's doc what about the
night starter I loved because it was
showing what happened right but also
cutting back to you guys enough about
the efforts you were making because
every time you go back to you guys
trying to to to get Justice for this it
kind of opens a window for the audience
to breathe for a minute right that show
on Netflix was nothing but just the most
expensive like Recreation it was like
Unsolved Mysteries without robber stack
it was just a recreation the whole thing
and we're like oh is there anything
redeeming about this no we're just gonna
watch and they're gonna and they got
order for two more and now he won the
Golden Globe so they're gonna keep
making these but I was like I'd rather
see the story of somebody who was trying
to stop them and I know that community
in that time that the cops weren't as
honest as I think they would wish they
were I hope they wish they were but you
know what's [__] up about
all of that the salaciousness of these
[__] crimes heinous [__] right is
that that's what moves the needle I know
you know that you know not knives out or
the [__] Glass Onion right Wednesday
okay dark I loved it you know yeah this
is reality just look at how many people
were scary movies have always been sure
I mean The Exorcist the head went around
and green said wait did you see it in
the theater it's making a [__]
statement scared the [__] out wait yeah
because you were the first time 30s the
20s you were young you had to be really
young oh yeah yeah
yeah I was uh 21 22. people lost it but
Texas Chainsaw Massacre did you go see
that in the theater here's my thing
about all that stuff at least that's
fiction this dollar thing was just
here's what happened and if it bothers
you oh don't worry it actually happened
like you never can like check out from
it like that I remember because of
growing up in Northern Illinois and and
uh Rockford is a town that we're just
south of he would Cruise in Rockford as
well in Chicago I remember the story of
the Filipino kid that he talked into the
uh first responding officers to go hey
you know and and and that people there
was such a different way I I hope we
progressed but we treated that Community
but I wanted to watch that what were
those police officers thinking when
they're when they're alone they thought
that like they were boyfriend who has a
bleeding [__] and the lady's like
that guy's not even of age 15. he's 15
with a bloody oil and they're like oh I
love his quarrel sorry guys anybody give
the dude back wow I'll get a hole in
this so since I remembered that from
being a kid when it happened and hearing
about it when it came up I tried
watching the show just so everybody know
I got about three episodes in when I got
to that I was like I can't this is right
but you know what I value yeah
I value your your opinion because you're
from where you're from yeah yeah where
there's no it's real there like there's
real people there's no [__] right
right and and right out here you're like
I don't know if it's the beginning you
know so yeah it's always somewhere else
in the midwest yeah yeah no [__] tell
you what's up yeah I I started watching
it and I watched it for whatever reason
I wonder the investigative side I want
to see what he did you know I want to
watch I want to watch what's interesting
to me the blood that God says bother me
so of course so
I was watching it my wife comes and says
what do you watch I said it's a Dahmer
thing but I'll change you don't have to
watch it no no I want to watch it so she
started watching it with me
and then she says that guy's sick yeah
why do you watch his stuff how can you
how can you stand to watch I said hey
dear you know I did this for a living
right of course and so I never went back
right because I turned it off
and I've never gone back to it see
because I got to watch it alone I can't
I still want to watch it I got to watch
it alone
I can [__] stay up and watch all of
at once Gil don't you think you'd get
frustrated watching the whole thing
being like guys you didn't right then
that was so slow I don't know because I
haven't seen it that far ah there's
there's gonna be Parts where you go guys
just
um
I get frustrated John uh Ramsay I got
frustrated really what about the
mattress like this [__] had a
mattress there I'm on my period you're a
guy
hemoids I got him I got hemorrhoids but
I mean
you're not talking about the place
smaller than this place yeah and
the the a wall uh air conditioner not
not Central
and then carpet all the [__] that can
have me sweater all this [__] that can
hold yeah that an end
I mean if that lady is still alive
we should try to see if we can find that
lady she is I think and talk to her you
know
and no and no consequence to the I mean
it was a long time ago to the police of
someone saying so so being at the store
if someone says I called you guys 10
times and now you [__] show up and he
kill people what's that what's your
answer hey [__] relax no I doubt it hey
talk to my friend George No but what do
you say though you know what somebody
says right you say hey if somebody said
you're a straight guy I I I'm I'm very
very sorry we will get to the bottom but
I don't know what cops were like I don't
know who was dealing with them because
back there you know it could have been
hey keep that in keep that to yourself
what about that lady out of our way what
about the the [__] guys took uh Drums
of chemicals out with guys people inside
insane wearing [__] hazmats and the
neighbors are always [__] white beard
barefooted with some shorts right that
is smells don't even those [__]
had protective [__] of course I think my
cousin when he got the guy out of the
cab of the semi he had to put on a full
house man to go in there and get that
just get that guy now I understand now I
understand why they would wear a
hazardous material
um suit because like that that smell
you'll never forget oh it and it'll
it'll get in your [__] clothes did
you get those clothes back
like you know like it's in your [__]
head you'll smell it all the time right
it's in your [__] psyche I've been
around I don't even say [__] psych
anywhere that's a [__] old I am so
you're [__] psyche I never said that
[__] I've been around that [__] I've
been through the fumes and probably I
can remember the ugliest one was the guy
bloated he was found in the what's worse
champagne farts or the dead body all the
dead bodies campaign
parts are pretty [__] rough man you
sit there and and the key to the whole
thing even with uh
is just don't go smell fresh air
so if you if you come into a room and
it's right here knock you out you stay
here you'll get used to it your nose is
the first sense to adapt yeah it's like
being on a farm you show up to a farm
and you're like this is horrible you
give it about five minutes you're not
gonna smell it that's why people don't
have cats
no now watch this something is simple
you go and you take a [__] in your own
restroom it's it's it's fine somebody
walks in right behind you say oh you big
somebody die in here you it didn't
bother you right you go out and you say
you're out for about a minute you say oh
[__] I forgot my keys I go back now you
go back in the restroom and now you're
set holy [__] this smells terrible you
know this is that's something I never
realized so it's true I didn't think
about it I knew about the farm thing but
I never thought in terms of your work
where you go just get in here get in
here don't go step out you step out
you're gonna throw up exactly don't step
outside your nose will to death once you
get that fresh air again it's going to
be just as bad oh my god when you went
in there wait is that your mind or is
that your it's your nose your your
senses
it becomes yeah because it becomes the
common denominator so your nose then
starts to see what does the new smell
like it's always yeah it just hits a new
Baseline do you remember Silence of the
Lambs when they pulled that girl out of
the river and they have her there in the
funeral home and they pass around that
little white thing and the old man yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's got Glenn right
and then the old man great face and when
they open it up in one move you know
like just ripping the Band-Aid off and
that old man went like just made a bit
of a slight face and you're like subtle
but you you see everything you know
exactly
you know and it was perfect little move
huh and they put that stuff under what
is that that well they've tried
everything mentholate them anything with
strong empty anything they try but it's
very simple you don't have to use that
you know if I was with a girl coffee you
know
if she was not as fresh down there I
would take my finger put it in my own
Guru and then make my own you set that
new Baseline now we got that's the new
normal I could take this now I've been
down over here hey hey when you go down
there don't come up here
you gotta stay here
that's your new normal that's it you go
down there till you're done don't take a
break hey hey put your feet in your ass
and put it right here man I gotta
[__] get out of here
wow man that's simple and you know I
don't think I don't think uh I think
there's a very small percentage of
people who will ever
stand in a six feet hole and look up and
still alive but I can say oh it's very
hot oh I hate it it's [__] Eerie dude
you wanna know the craziest thing about
working in a cemetery at least the one
where I worked at they had you would
take this long probably maybe somewhere
between
six and nine feet long metal rod at the
top of it it would have it would y up at
the top you'd almost use the top of the
Y like handlebars
you push that thing down and far into
the ground as you could and then uh
before you could go any farther you just
get maybe like six feet down you start
turning it and we were looking for bones
because in this Cemetery they had popper
Graves so they would just bury people
with nothing and there's no markings so
you can't go with a backhoe and start
making your grave and then you pulling
up ribs so you gotta and you could feel
the bones of where they see that that
would [__] for me that would [__] with
you yeah there's no smell I I I just
knowing that I'm moving around somebody
else that was once there so the bones
are what's means yeah everything that
was there right yeah close so you have
to make sure because you think you'd
have a lot like the cemetery's been
around since uh late 1800s so you would
have these places where you would you
would just we don't know if that's an
empty lot or if there's a popper buried
there and you'd have to go find you'd
have to try and find close deteriorate a
lot super fast if they've been if
they've been in oh they would yeah not
those [__] jewelry jewelry and Bones
not those Apache jeans you get at
[__] JCPenney those [__] are
Rodney the robot that [__] can
try to burn through those jeans we had
an area of the cemetery that uh forgive
me for this turn I don't know what the
new term would be but uh we it was just
called the Gypsy section of the ground
yeah yeah and that's a turtle yeah yeah
and well I'm not supposed people hey
you're up they give you a flower
and they hadn't there was a area there
that had like a kiln like a big like
Fire and Fire Double Trouble boil bubble
Kiln right and uh one night these high
school kids
dragged that killing out of there on the
back of a truck and then two nights all
the way around yes and then two nights
later my boss John Loggins he came back
into work and there was a brand new Kiln
there and no one ever visited those
Graves and they didn't see anybody come
in or come out and granted he leaves at
night and he comes back and morning but
that pla that area was always like up
kept and it had its own little like
Trinkets and things about it and you
just didn't mess with it Whoa man yeah
yeah there's people they were things
going on they were out there too in the
Gypsies and I think that's the only
thing you know what in this in this
world in this country there's still
things like that that oh little people
have never seen Society in Europe in
Europe uh
you know we went but we went ballooning
in the Lower Valley right with of course
when I was married well you know didn't
cost them but you got in a hot air
balloon
and uh so you're risking your life and
you fly over the camps
and I said hey don't look at them in
their eyes because you're not you're
probably 20 feet 30 on your way up
because they'll steal your soul who
everybody saw the lady started crying
I'm like there's a [__] blue I made
it up
you know I [__] started crying man
[Music]
but I mean I said don't look at him
still steal your soul I look at their
[__] crying and they're all huddled
down I'm like well it's gonna be a
[__] great trip I said I made it up
no you did I said I made it up you you
got stuff in your culture where they're
like witches and oh yeah and we don't do
this
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah put
those what's the other one the latrusa
if a [__] man ties a knot right here
that's scarier to me than the [__]
look she said
I learned my college roommates you'll
catch my college roommate from Texas
she's a Mexican and he was teaching me
all this [__] I'm like what do you tell
he's like dude the little shoes is going
to get your ass what's up
curse right it's a curse it's the
[__] owl or the man head
oh by the way were they [__] I don't
know
somebody [__] an hour and you know
probably the dude thought out it'll be
my body but nobody will know it's me
it's the [__] hey [__] you
[__] an owl
hey hey bring that all over here you
believe in curses yes you do you think
you could be cursed
no I don't I think that somebody could
put a cursor yes and I think that's
somebody here you go no I don't know
it's energy man you know but I do
believe in energy after you believe in
energy then you would believe that
somebody like you know uh you know
[__] Gypsy yeah whatever yeah blank
is out there and if they believe enough
they'll send you that [__] negative
energy
and maybe it doesn't make a difference
maybe it does I don't know maybe it's uh
he took one to jail she started foaming
at the mob and now she's gonna put a
curse on really yeah and put a night a
pencil through my neck not any help but
a pencil through my neck and I was gonna
have a curse and I said well curse me to
get thin [__] you're going to jail
anyway I don't care that's what you told
her yeah so did the curse take no did
anybody ever look at me I'm gonna let
you say it it's dinner for back then uh
one day I'm gonna help to know you long
enough so you can zip that best but
anyways I don't know how long I got but
uh did you ever uh have somebody blow
you like for to let them go
I guarantee you got offered there is no
way you didn't get off no
look at this look at that
you get it all right your friendship is
complete now [__] there's another Studio
missing the [__] lightning
[__] a soundproof lady
that's what you got offered hey man I
just met you and I [__] you act right
yeah I'm gonna put this [__] in
my show oh I would do it this is good
I'm gonna put you you're gonna be one of
the movers you're gonna be one of those
you'll be the only white mover everybody
think you're the boss I already I don't
know if I'm looking at you like
everybody hey you're the boss I'm the
boss I think you would be perfect dude
hey any scenario where I can end up
without drinking those pacificos that's
all I wanted isn't it great you seen the
shot yeah man that was [__] amazing
we were talking about it today [__]
Alex I told Al five years ago hey I'm
gonna have you play my best friend you
know I don't know because I got a deal
that fox [__] Fox and making any Joe's
got a [__] office at CBS it's like Al
don't [__] this up man yeah you know
don't [__] this up he's great he's great
in the show man family comedy but but
the realness exactly yeah yeah yeah this
oh they're already air but there's a
there's a thing that he told you about
the thing with the pictures that we did
in the band no
man it's one
it may be it was just last Friday wasn't
it no that's his Friday it may it may be
the funniest thing that I've ever been a
part of and I've been a part of some fun
were you breaking
or or or when you thought of it it got
you yeah okay but every there's a couple
of things you know with Rita the scene
with Rita everybody watched the scene
like the host crew and doing the
rehearsal and all that stuff like they
go over
um and you know there's a there's a
there's a guy veto the guy a cameraman
he's like
he would just say like
when you're done
great job boss and then you're like you
know it's [__] nice man and then the
one with Al and Matt and they're making
the tamales and he's got like the guy
Matt goes I got this recipe from the
Barefoot Contessa with tamales with
walnuts they [__] hell slap that
[__] bag out of his head and then
they do Like Water for Chocolate oh my
God that was another thing where people
were
people the [__] students it's like a
state right so the studio Network
everybody would stand around in a little
because you're in the kitchen yeah yeah
and when they were done they were
[__] clap like you're watching them
[__] like oh that's like [__]
theater
I mean they would clap the other day
when you ate the doggy treats
hey if she says it's my God
that's my favorite thing to do oh it is
and the old the old lady was right there
she was laughing just as hard as I was
talking stuff but it was funny oh man my
daughter's like man she's that's the
best part of it you guys doing that
together I mean so hard yeah dude I
would love to have you on the show in a
heartbeat yeah I think it's different
also it's the dream a good like just a
good sitcom a network TV because when
they hit and you could do them right and
you're having fun it's the best job in
the world you know
um
yeah it is it's all it's also unexpected
like the first the first one
is a bit of a fluke you know the first
one so 20 years ago by it and Bruce even
said Bruce said this should be easy
easier for you because 20 years ago you
had to introduce yourself to people
right and now they know who I am like
whether they like me or not yeah so
you're a bit of like I like they're
going to a restaurant they already know
and then the the Gen Z the anxiety show
or mine doesn't speak Spanish is what's
resonating with the younger kids so
that's where the show lies not with me
I'm like I'm like the older and my mind
is closed so that's that's my part I'm a
close mind right and then they are you
don't understand my generational trauma
you're responsible for my trauma we
don't put a name on it this and I don't
know what and even if you don't know
what it is it's something to them right
where they would say you know my brother
would be like
but I would be like what's the matter
I'm sad well you better get [__]
happy because they're [__] leaving
right you're just like right that was it
right I'm sad boy you better get [__]
happy because go outside you go outside
go outside every one of your characters
is coming into their own yeah the little
kid uh my son told me you're almost
son-in-law on the show she's coming into
it if you look at that guy if you if you
look at like if this was a football game
and you say I'm gonna watch this guy
that guy is really good like he was he
did some shows did a child actor so he
was good and that [__] has like
a photographic memory and selling nice
was on Orange Is the New Black and that
single camera five six years of
surrounded by women like the whole time
it can't be easy and now she comes into
this thing where she and she got the
part
because she we can go dramatic and then
you can go happy and you can say you can
have those hard
you know I don't want mine to lose
respect for you but don't be crazy
mine's never respected you I mean just
fine and not make it sound like it's a
joke well that's right that's what I'm
saying the real you said edge but I was
saying the realness the realness of it
and that's where and that's where and
that's where I think it that's why I
mean
for and I've had a nice career I've
never had a show be
as universally approved of so fast like
I said the other one was just great you
know but yeah thank you and I'd love to
have it oh and a heartbeat yeah I used
to work in your field is that right I
was a federal agent cool where at uh
there's John C Kozinski building [__]
wait a minute I know where that is in
Chicago the big all those they have
those three big black buildings it's
over like they're all caddy corner from
each other I was in college
and they were hiring interns no I was uh
I was uh I was in no it's all recorded
it's all recorded uh I was in um uh OPM
the office of personnel management so we
did background investigations for
military and civilians and uh I was
still going to college at the same time
I had a federal badge had everything one
time I walked up there's like a minimum
security prison right in downtown
Chicago like in the loop and I there was
a door that you would use it was also
had the parking garage attached to it
for the federal buildings and so this is
late at night I get done with work I'm
walking back up I'm probably 20 21 years
old and there's a tile non-descript tile
where you know to put your fob so that
the door opens but if you don't if
you're not supposed to be there you
don't know which tile is the fob right
yeah it's the closest I ever got to any
James Bond stuff and so I walk up and
this other guy walks up at the exact
same point as me and so I kind of go go
ahead because I don't know him and he
doesn't mean he goes hey you go first
and I go no it's fine man you you I'm
happy to get the door for you open it
and he goes how about you just uh open
it and now we're in a bit of a tattoo
here and so I go hey
I'm officer personal management I'm
supposed to be here and he gets back his
jacket
federal U.S Marshal with his Glock right
next to it and I go you know what let me
get that door yeah I was like hey you
win you win I'm just doing background
investigation you're out here you're
you're you're you're you're ranging did
you want to do that
like I was going to school to be I was
in theater school I was a thief I felt
like I was in a TV show I'm a theater
school kid also being a federal agent
but I had access to the FBI Mainframe
they had to do a full level uh like I
had national security clearance yeah
yeah where they do that sf-86 and they
go to like your high school teachers and
people who you grew up with and ask you
all they would ask you like they would
ask uh would Daniel be willing to shave
every day for work if he had to and then
the person my college roommate Paul hey
Paul Lopez he would go uh yeah yeah he
would okay has he ever been a part of
any organizations to overthrow the
government by violent or non-violent
forces and of course they're throwing
you off by asking you like all these
things he was like no you know and Paul
had no idea and I was just flying by the
seat of my pants and so I ended up being
a federal agent on 9 11 we had to like
shut down our access to the Mainframe it
was scary scary time but yeah so I I did
that you were there at 9 11. you were
there you were wow yeah yeah I remember
my mom called me up and I was like she's
like don't go to work today I think I'm
one of the people who have to go to work
today yeah I'm a federal agent so yeah I
went in and then we closed everything
down like really quick but then they
moved their offices out to the suburbs
and I couldn't still go to the school in
Chicago and go out to the suburb I
didn't have a car or anything but and I
was saying they recruited you from the
school or it was like a job fair this is
the wildest thing in the world I'm like
I think they do that at the job fair but
they're non-descript I think they were I
think they're not telling you what they
are if you come up they might assess you
right and just say okay there might be
somebody there sure okay right every
person I worked with if you go through
OPM it's kind of like a back door way
into the FBI or CIA because you're kind
of get you get in now you're with an
agency that's technically doing
investigations and you're part of that
the FBI like I had an FBI ID number and
all that stuff so you're in and then you
kind of can like move into another spot
because it can be obviously so hard to
get in DEA CIA FBI and so they were
doing a job fair and I was walking
through the building to go to my job
that I had then I was just a server at a
little Diner in Chicago and I had to
wear like a white button-up shirt and
black slack so I kind of looked okay to
walk up to a business thing and I talked
to the guy and he goes yeah his name was
Jack Phillips talk like this hey I'm
Jake Phillips how you doing hey he was a
20-year state trooper and a 20-year IRS
investigations and now he was doing this
[__]
and so he was like what's your name I'm
like Dan Daniel Van Kirk he's all right
Daniel what you're gonna do fill this
out fakes it to me just tell me a little
bit about yourself and who you are but
all he was doing is that what he sounded
like exactly like a great boy what he
was doing was just saying can this kid
just do attack
he's like all right Daniel I'm gonna
have you come in you're gonna meet here
you're gonna go through a security
checkpoint all this stuff and I'm like
okay so I go there and he goes we'd like
to bring you on You're Gonna Fill out
this form that's why I got the sf86 and
yeah I ended up I was in two meetings
that they were like hey part of your
clearance uh you could never speak about
what we talk about in this meeting it
was like natural security stuff and
things and I'm guys I'm 20. I'm a
freaking theater kid sitting there like
whatever you say it was a wild I had a
badge that was the best you ever bet you
ever take your badge to Chicago I was in
Chicago last year I was retired I still
carry bed but I was you put that badge
and I'm telling you as a 20 year old you
put that badge on any table on any bar
you will not be paying you will be
paying maybe a third of Whatever You're
Building Chicago and my boss told me he
goes he goes here he goes you're allowed
to carry a gun we don't want you
carrying a gun I go okay I don't need to
carry a gun but they you ever want to go
into a bar 20 years old you show them
that badge it's Chicago they're gonna
let you walk right in I had a great
20-year my 20th year was pretty fun yeah
that's what's great about it yeah and
that's what's great about Chicago is you
know it's very old school in that way of
like and none of it was ever you know
everybody was nice and I would have felt
out in any way anybody knew nobody
needed to hey Pop those [__] titties
[__] your badge is melted [__]
chocolate sir this is a family Hooters
I'll be right back yeah um that was that
was my closest time to uh working and
your experts and then at what point did
you say
I'm gonna move on when they uh when they
went to after 9 11. because I couldn't
do both
it was scary too because one of those
planes was supposed to come there but
then um like to those buildings and they
grounded it before it could take when
they when they grounded everything good
thing they probably didn't have that key
fob for the right time I know right yeah
um but it was wild because I didn't want
to everybody wanted to do it and I I was
like yeah they're like what are you
doing here I don't know I fell backwards
into this job I think it might have it
might have been good to give you a taste
of what oh first sure because you know
now you understand how people can go
undetected you know what the thing I
learned most that you know a thousand
times better than us so these kids would
join the Navy right and the recruiters
they don't care don't talk about the
time you got arrested don't do whatever
just don't put it on there and you'll
hold it you'll get it [__] and to be
honest nobody really does care that you
when you were 17 you got busted for weed
nobody gives a [__] okay but they would
do this stuff when they got into the
Navy they would then get like uh
security clearance to like be on a sub
and a lot of our subs had like nuclear
reactors on them and stuff so now wow
that is when they would have to get this
bigger clearance man these poor kids now
they're like 19 20 years old and even
though I was the same age yeah we you
would say to them like hey
fill this out uh you know you're gonna
do an interview and they would do the
interview and they would say things that
no one would have ever asked them that
they never needed to bring up the amount
of people and hopefully a lot of times
to your benefit that don't know when to
shut up when you're talking to and I
would sometimes I would like tell these
kids like hey or they'd they'd like
you'd have reference you know the reason
the guy went and talked to Paul Lopez in
my room is because I put Paul's name
down some of these people would put
people's names down that you're like
don't send us to go talk to them that
person doesn't even like you right but
they would they would they would confess
things and like say things that you were
just like no one was ever going to ask
but you know part of law enforcement is
just letting the letting that wrong
letting the untrained be around the
trained right so Bubba goes in there and
he's like I was watching you know I was
watching crime there was a there was a
police officer that was accused of using
Snapchat and sending pictures and the
guy goes in there sitting there just two
women and they were and they're breaking
down the woman has said nothing about
anything just about hey where did you
play sports and the guy's breaking it
down that's uh JCS and they do profile
dreading sure and they the guy breaks
down go stop and he goes okay see how
the woman hasn't said anything there's a
second woman there and she hasn't said
anything at all and this one is like
friendly but not then it slides to
you have a Snapchat you had an insta you
were sending I'd do it on Snapchat and
they some they were underage and the way
that they did it
what the guy goes you have a picture
that I can see and she's like
um yeah I mean do you want to see it
yeah I'd like to see it and you know
we're not keeping you of course they say
we're not keeping you can leave that
[__] looked over there and he
goes I think I would like an attorney
you know I'm not answering more
questions and then the lady says well
could I ask you a couple of things okay
that's the first time she spoke
and the guy said see how she was quiet
the whole time and then there was no
lawyer and there was like almost he was
done she was done with him right and
just slide just because he hasn't talked
to her yet yeah and she said yeah sure
and there was just two things and then I
put my [__] got 12 years
oh it's old it's called you're asking
controlled questions so yes stuff that
he doesn't have fear of that he'll give
you a legitimate answer and then those
are all controlled and when he least
expects it now ask him another question
just a soft but only now and as it's to
the core of what you're looking and he
was putting this together
as they were asking slight you know like
a sliver of a of a thing like did you
ever did anybody what name did you use
you know have you ever
did you ever send any you know was there
any videos of would you say uh you know
we're not a confiscate trip they had a
search warrant already so he sat down
right they already had a search warrant
right when you're sitting there they're
searching your house right because they
know where you are sure right and then
they had a search warrant and and said
we'll need to you know confiscate your
phone and he's like uh uh today yes sir
uh we have a uh
um a warrant a warrant and confiscate
the phone yeah and and he was majorly
[__] but when he walked in there
you know he sat like this you know he
and I think in his mind he thought I'm a
police officer yeah maybe I've done this
but I think they'll be on my side they
haven't brought anything up right he
didn't know he he knew but he didn't I
mean you know what you've what you've
done and then they had them in enough
more than enough to where when they
finally started to I mean it's masterful
right just a little bit of a thing yeah
and they had enough on that LAPD officer
the female that went for murder
Stephanie Lazarus yes when they brought
her in
they they brought her in and she was a
[__] nut and she was and she was
almost mental almost like mentally and
scientifically equivalent of being a
police she was an investigator really
investigator and them going head to head
is crazy because it's a sociopath too
[__] murder and then you're
going with the trained and then that
versus the training of the the good side
versus the good side and the
relationship dude right and it goes and
they're go right almost like willing to
answer any questions they had she was
into art uh theft uh Arts they were in
so they said hey we got a case at the
Walmart so they're asking her a bunch of
control questions nothing to do with any
criminal investment and then all of a
sudden okay well listen now we want to
talk to you about do you know this you
know this and she says hey wait a minute
you know maybe it's time I need an
attorney because you're asking me
questions you think you're calling me
you think I don't know and so she
stopped it soon as they change the
question but by then she was she was
already in oh they had her and she's in
prison now no the psychology of it as
she should be the psychology of
everything is
is way more the it's almost like
expecting you know when you're [__]
with somebody like that it's almost like
you have a [__] Lamborghini uh car
and you you have maybe uh you know
[__] BMW you think you you think you
think you know [__] but you don't know
[__] right unless you've been trained
like that guy very bad but still very on
the point he's not using any more words
than he needs to use yeah right well can
I ask you a question sure and forgive me
if it's ever been asked no no don't be
modest 38 what that does 38 [__] G
what
how much of your you're regarded as such
a great investigator and a detective as
a cop right how much of that do you feel
is innate and how much of it do you feel
was learned
that you were born to do this versus
well because you obviously you always
think you have to learn tools that you
need to learn how to use and tactics but
I'm sure you met enough people to go
because what do they say what do they
call the person who finishes last in med
school a doctor yeah so so there's
people who were good enough to like get
the uniform but then I'm sure and I
would say you and other people that you
worked with that that that that guy was
born to be a cop that guy was born to be
a detective he was born to investigate
break people down figure out the truth
and get to it like how much of that do
you get don't be modest okay I I believe
one of my one of my dear friends who uh
solved the Mickey Thompson case uh
that's a big case and and what's his
name mark Lillian field and my wife knew
if anything ever happened to me get mark
on the case yeah a lot of guys didn't
like him because they were jealous you
know they they kind of do it and and it
was just too bad because he was
brilliant isn't it all [__] high
school anyways he was a [__]
investigator you're all on the same side
and they don't like him because he's
smart yeah he's brilliant he was
brilliant and what happened so he told
me you know I was down at the office one
day I was on loan to the sheriff and I
had to go back to the office I'm
studying for lieutenants exam and he saw
me in the office and he said before you
go I want to talk to you and I said okay
so I'm done I said well how far along is
he how much older than you is he at this
I mean he's younger than I am he's
younger yeah he's younger than I am okay
and uh he is he is Heir he didn't need
this job he's heir to Levi J Strauss
holy from his family you know and he he
says I said okay what do you want to
talk about I said well listen you ask
him how come they make the [__] holes
not sewn big enough for the button
right on the jacket the jackets are the
worst you almost have to do this with
everything in the head that it's going
to stretch right so it's [__] tight
when you bite I mean that's [__] bro
all right anyways sorry so
I said let's talk he said well let's go
outside you want to go outside and I
said what is it Mark he says I want to
tell you you low-life scum sucking piece
of [__] you suck [__] through a straw
you're so [__] up and he's telling me
this and I'm saying okay he says don't
get me wrong
you saw him telling you this because I
believe the good Lord has put us here
everybody has put us here for a reason
in life he says and you were put here to
be an investigator because you're a
goddamn good one you're one of the best
you start crying again you believe
I believe and you know you should be an
investigator now I hear you talking
about studying for that [__]
Lieutenant's exam you want to push
[__] pencils that's a waste of
[__] time and effort you belong here
on the floor damn and I said well thank
you I'm not pissed off you know I thank
you for the vote of confidence but you
know uh did you Felch to the [__]
straw problems
but do you say you didn't see that in
yourself no I I was studying to be
Lieutenant because I was told getting
close I'm getting old you know retired
you know if you make it more money uh
for retirement I said I'm going to take
the test I'm going to take lieutenants
with him I said I'm studying
if I don't make it I'll come back here
as an investigator as a sergeant they've
already told me I can come back anytime
I want
or they can throw my ass out if they if
I'm not performing yeah
so I said I probably won't pass the test
look at this skin I'm Mexican I probably
won't pass the test and if I don't I'll
come back but if I do I'll be able to
come back and I'll be able to Mentor
I'll be able to help sure be able to
teach
and he said okay so that part
nobody taught me that part you know that
was in me okay the actual
Case Of The Night Stalker
that was partly in me but a big part was
on it on a professor I had for due
semester at Cal State LA Dr Robert
Morneau or Bob as I called him who
taught me advanced criminal
investigation pertaining to sex workers
he made me identify made me see allowed
me to see right things that the average
investigator none of the guys in the
bureau saw I saw it and recognized it
for what it was and he gave me that
knowledge I didn't have that knowledge
but maybe it's more like you were born
to be a sponge for that like for us it
was being a comedian anybody can go do a
bad set right right but a comic earlier
in your career if you're going to be a
headlining comic the the sponge is
somebody who realizes well this worked
this didn't work for that reason and so
every time you get more of that stage
time and more of that knowledge you get
closer and closer to being good at it so
you were a sponge for that that's like
you're one of the best sponges for
comments but you need to have a
consistency level of like for yourself
wherever you went to a different town
whatever in the 90 80 90 percent
effective like they go oh that
[__] sucked last night tonight
was good last night not so good you
needed to find the consistency somewhere
and that's that and that's also
instinctual
things go out things come in you know
guys try to do too much you just want
you just want to especially in the
beginning just drive that [__] car
right down the middle yeah I can
remember taking one of his classes and
he was talking about you like to see the
fear in someone's eyes and that's a
sexual appearance yeah yeah and so
somebody had been arrested at night on a
Sunday night cruising Whittier World War
and he stuck a gun in a girl's ribs and
said kiss me and then go and then they
got stopped to get some booze and they
ended up shirt and they got busted he
got busted detective came in there
and night detective went in there
interviewed him I come in Monday
mornings I was working day shift
detectives and I see the night deck he
had gone to court and he says hey by the
way I interviewed your guy they were
some [__] [__] on a Whittier
Boulevard he says they were just out
there picking up they just got bummed
out this guy was a starter pistol that
was inoperative he said it was [__] up
he's nothing I sent him down to CJ and
it'll be a D.A reject
I said okay thank you Bobby yeah this
was a seasoned detective right so I got
my partner I said hey come on I want to
go interview this guy
these wood has already been there I said
come on go with me I want to go in so I
went to interview I knew the family I
had arrested his brother before and I
went down there and I said you know
you've been advised your constitutional
rights I said I want to do it again so I
don't want anybody to say we've tried to
[__] with you this is good I like this
so we we talked just being thorough it's
not you it's us it's not you it's just
it's entertain me and and by the way
before we even talk about your case I
got to tell you I've read the reports
and by the grace of God I'm here today
I'm [__] lucky
because I got to that part where you
stuck the gun in the wrist now you're on
his side now he thinks you guys I said
it reminded me of when I was a kid and
when I was a kid I was a [__] peeping
Tom
I said and I'd go look in Windows he
says let's face it all women are pretty
he says but I'm [__] looking when I
see those chichis out and I'd start
whacking off I said just before I'm
gonna bust a nut I'd tap on the window
he says and then I'd get away and when I
saw this [__] report you stuck the
gun in there and said kiss me that's
what it brought me back to and he said
now yeah you guys are peas in a pod and
he says yeah that's why I did it it was
awesome kill and so now now I get him to
[__] cop out of everything and the
guy went to jail for [__] kidnapping
an unlawful detention [__] yeah [__] him
and you played him from the moment he
would have gone you know he'd be kicked
out he'd walk yeah they'd kicked him out
he had walked
got him to cop out they filed they got
everything and and [__] like and I I
still get chills right out just thinking
about course but we did but that
was knowledge that I gained from Bob
Morneau wow but that's being a sponge
you took that I took I even had
permission from the Department I was
such a believer in the guy permission
from the Department to bring him in as a
consultant he was a professor so I went
to the he was on sabbatical
he was in Greece at the time we saw the
caves put together what is sabbatical by
the way like a vacation yeah they get
that like three five month vacation oh
is that what that is it's usually long
yeah so after the case was we solved it
I got to go back one of the highlights
was going back and I said you
you gave me the knowledge to work this
that's awesome and we sat there and we
[__] he was a good guy yeah but see
that's the thing the sponge I mean yeah
a lot of people in those classes didn't
take that where one guy leaves
and they're like yo give it up so no no
no let me just let me [__] just go
talk to him I mean he would have [__]
walked he would have kept doing what he
was doing exactly he would have kept
doing what he was doing oh for sure and
who knows and it always escalates right
yeah because the fear and he was a sauce
like your nose that bass line just keeps
setting yeah and So eventually that's
not enough fear I need a little bit of
more fear I'm that that fear is boring
that fear is old I need new fear and it
just keeps going and [__] going and
going that's right he was a wannabe his
younger brother was a little hardcore
gangbanger fighter you know doing
everything I started seeing his brother
on the street probably he's about 10
years old
and I had popped his brother Bunches of
times what was he doing at 10 like
stealing [__] I don't know what are you
out on Whittier Boulevard hanging around
trying to get steel beer still in they
can being one of the boys everything's
going down on Whittier oh man that used
to be crazy I'm not anymore
I was in a restaurant just the other day
to go over there with my sister
two for 20 on this blanket
hello
my brother-in-law is having surgery he
had a knee replacement on Thursday I
picked up my sister I said well he's
having let's go out local have have some
lunch so we go we sit down we eat and
finish eating there's some guy sitting
at the table with a lady
get up to leave and he says you don't
remember he looked at me says
you don't remember me do you and I
looked and I said no I'm sorry I don't
sir he says really take another look I
said sir are you carrying at this point
no you might almost have to know that
and normally I do you're sitting down
this is your high profile person and I
said sir I'm sorry I really don't
remember you want to refresh my memory
he says yeah you arrested me about 10
times
and I just started laughing he clicked I
I still didn't recognize I don't
remember him but he was friends with
George Verdugo the guy that helped me
out on that that case a guy that's a
multi-millionaire now
neighborhood same neighborhood and I
remember the neighborhood I remember the
guy but he's this guy George was a
documentary oh yeah there's a guy that
was on the street hopeless and he said
hey yeah get the [__] out of town get
the [__] out of here you said this to
him oh he he was he became a multi
millionaire doing what yeah he's now he
buys these uh what do you know websites
or what do they call them the domain the
name domain domain name okay yeah as an
example years ago the Rams are in St
Louis he bought larams.com oh my gosh
how much is that worth to sell it back
to the Rams yeah yeah yeah so bought
other domains like that he's got a
domain in East LA wait
I got George lopez.com I had to buy that
one back there's a [__] again my
friend yeah three thousand dollars he
took it from you my friend no no he's in
San Antonio I don't know if you I don't
know if you should keep saying friend
well he was not about my friend I
haven't seen it wait are you is that are
you from San Antonio no he was oh I was
gonna say I bought it you were we went
to go look hi Paul Lopez my college Room
San Antonio yeah and uh
they're like hey some dude
owns her he says he knows you and I was
like and I found out who was like this
[__] [__] three grand back
there 30 years ago 25 years ago yeah
that's that's you go for inflation
that's that's still open
uh so so what were you saying oh so
we're gonna go wait so you told them to
get out of town
so you're seeing this guy on Whittier
Boulevard all the time I no George
Perdue
I was lecturing in
San Clemente okay some guy comes up and
he says hey you know I I got this uh do
you have any murders in East L.A and I
said yeah I got him earn we talked about
it it's kind of a kind of a rhetorical
question and so we we yeah and his
brother without exposing everything his
brother got involved okay and I said he
said this guy was a parole agent he said
my brother
he's not like me he's different I said
I'm not even gonna bother you brother
here's my card have him give me a call
if he wants to perfect and he called I
called we established we met had a
friendship the guy was good as gold and
he says well I don't know if I could do
all this I'm talking to you you know I
gotta by now he says I gotta talk to God
and I started laughing and he says I'm
serious that's not a laughing matter I
said no no I'm laughing that's happiness
because God wouldn't have brought me
here today if you weren't good
and so two hours later his angles
so two hours later he called me and said
hey I'm in and so we talked and later on
in life I helped him out of some scraps
that he got into you know we got to do
this we got to do this and this is what
you got to do and he left he left town
and he'd call me up every once in a
while and he says Gil I'm praying for
you I said I need all the prayers I can
get brother keep them coming sir well
now he did then he became a minister and
he went went East and now he I want to
say he's in Kansas and the house you say
hey Gil this is my new gig my new digs
it's a it's a [__] Mansion it's not a
house
and he's bought up all these things and
now his latest adventure with his
brother who used to be in Pearl now he's
buying uh he's into wheat you know he's
got Labs yeah and and that she says
after the money that gill yeah the guy's
a wise investor
the guy the guy could buy me yeah no
you're high priced uh how many years are
you on patrol uh actual Patrol work I
did from 74 to 81 and then 81 I went in
to investigate I got a couple buddies
there's they're on patrol
81. but also he went to Vietnam too so
you're a numb that was before I became
that to me listen to me
um
man going to war
for I couldn't even I was going for a
country you're not going because to do
some score like let's go ahead I mean is
I mean
it's just it's just you know they
appreciate I mean you know you know I
said I and I you know how people say
that you you live like other lives
um when I when the LAPD wanted me to
help them try to recruit new officers
the it was on the radio in 2000 I went
to uh the thing over there in Sylmar
where they had the training and they had
a paintball thing and I could I could
not
be shot at or I couldn't shoot somebody
like I never knew I wasn't a gun person
but I couldn't put the helmet on and put
the vest on and go out there and when
the guy comes out you might get shot I
couldn't do it you're 100 I I couldn't
shoot at somebody and more importantly I
didn't want to be shot at right
and then some lady read me like years
later and she was like you you're
welcome
[Applause]
but I I think something happened to me
in previous lives where where
it I would not want to engage I would
say you're pretty normal
I would say the average person feels
exactly how you I don't know man you
know what I mean for all the people and
I I my whole life was growing up around
uh guns and people who uh served Arts
country and stuff like that we had my
grandpa had him I just knew you were
raised Jack Phillips the guy my boss
here he told me he goes are they the
only thing how you have a gun around a
kid and I said okay he goes my
daughter's five years old all right and
now I know I always keep my gun locked
up when I was coming home from uh when I
get home
but what if someday I accidentally were
in the rush we go to the dinner whatever
I leave it out on the table she's got a
babysitter I don't think about it so
what I did with my daughter was five
took her out I had her shoot the gun I
had her clean the gun I'm tired I put
the gun back together he goes by the
time she's five she didn't like how that
felt when she shot it he goes by the
time we were done with that day she
couldn't give two shits about that gun
he goes his thing was I took all the
mystery away from it that it was my tool
that I used she didn't like the way it
felt when she shot it she knew exactly
how it worked and he still locked it up
all the time but his fear was that
someday it would be a scenario it was
out and she would wonder oh that's a gun
that's my dad's gun and he wanted his
strategy and everybody has their own
lives their own personal life but his
was I need to remove all magic and
mystery away from this weapon so that
she doesn't give a [__] about what it
was and that was his that was you know I
kind of grew up the same way of just
being around but I think that isn't it
brilliant I think it's brilliant do you
like that do you hate it you don't like
it no I just you can I worked in the
[__]
I worked with a guy that was
and I'm not going to mention any names
I always met your [__] days
especially the [__] you can't call
me any [__] name you wanted nobody
knows everybody knows my friends
we protect the [__] I don't want this
guy's a real piece of [__]
he'll steal your life he's dead now he's
dead he's definitely say his name and so
he caught his son my biggest fear I had
three kids two daughters and a son my
biggest fear was one of my kids grabbing
the guns I was never worried about the
girls yeah the boys are curious so I was
always afraid fortunately never had a
problem now in adulthood my son cops out
one time he found my gun in the car and
he was showing it to his cousin my
nephew but then he put it right back he
said no I'll get in trouble and he put
it back but God damn that scared me even
now but but my old you guys I used to
work with I'm telling the story how I
you know uh what's going on and he says
yeah he says I found my kid playing with
my gun one time he says so I [__]
took him out to the [__] desert I
gotta shoot my God a shotgun first she
says got a shotgun and I got a [__] a
chicken I said shoot the [__]
made him shoot the [__] chicken watch
the [__] chicken go to Pieces the
hell never wanted he says he'll never
want to do that again I said God
damn it's not worth the bucket it's not
worth it but what you're saying about
now I think that that is very true I
think that most people have this idea of
I'll have a gun I can shoot a gun but
when it came down to it like my I have a
friend his name was Dirk he's he's
talked about it publicly he did I think
six years in the Navy got out went to
college kind of felt like it wasn't him
went back into the army kept his years
in his pay grade and his rank right goes
off to Afghanistan and he gets shot in
Afghanistan takes a round like into the
hip he um he uh you know what he doesn't
I'm gonna break I saw that dude he he
ends up the documentary no no no he ends
up laying down cover fire while they're
dragging him and I'm saying it because
he won't brag on himself so I'm going to
uh bronze star purple purple yeah and
you know even him and he won't mind me
saying this either that was obviously a
traumatic thing for him to work through
shooting at people and being shot at
obviously and and I think that for the
average person they don't think about
like the weight that comes with doing
that there was like I know a guy but
also when you don't have a choice and
you go well when you don't have a choice
when you don't have a you're in a
difference that's War but but but but
even a lot of those guys I mean you know
I had a stepdad and and he was he was
the same thing it was a lot for him to
process so you talk about you I don't
want to get shot I think that's normal
would you agree I mean I don't know I I
don't know I just felt that I just felt
like it was the people who I was the
only one out of everybody that was there
I made iced tea for everyone
I went there I made it it wasn't my
thing so glad I'm I'm a lucky man I
didn't come back uh traumatized like
some of these guys do and I made it but
you heard that [__] hitting the [__]
helicopter oh yeah you'd hear him you'd
shoot you knew what you had to do you
panic you died so don't panic and I
learned to laugh at everything that's
the best I mean that's that yeah you're
like oh oh look somebody sent this
[__] seven guys in here
all right Miguel I would also say based
on your entire life's work you were made
to be able to handle extremely high
stressful situations and deal with
things and mentally process you can't
even yeah you know even even if you had
only been a police officer and you're
like you know a lot of guys that really
have to have a hard time with the stuff
they've seen you seem to be a person
whether it's laughter or your faith or
anything at all where you're like I have
done my way of processing this and if
you didn't process it that's how you end
up very you gotta get it out I learned I
learned that in Vietnam I had a process
don't stress this is how you do it this
way God bless you for your service and
for your ability to take care of
yourself then I came back and I've lived
that and it and it was simple so if I
told my kid be home at three o'clock
yeah I had one kid that would come home
at 259 and like put her toe right there
at the door until hey I made it the
other kid had come home at 303.
and I'm there sitting down with my
friend and my daughters hey I'm home and
I said you're late
yeah you know you you gotta you make
rules you gotta follow them we're gonna
go out shoot the chicken
[__] chicken loaded we're going out
so it just that that's the way I've
lived and do you think that um
do you think that there's officers out
there guys that have years on in Patrol
or wherever that don't want to take the
next level because of the amount of work
or maybe inside you know something to
say hey man you know what I'm happy here
but don't challenge themselves maybe
they have the ability they just don't
want stress level I think they're afraid
of failing man they don't want to go out
there and fail I could see you but you
looked at it as you couldn't fail yeah
even if because of uh the color of your
skin you weren't going to make it to the
next level you were like well then I'm
going to take this opportunity yeah so
you you don't even even it just the
amount of time to hang out with you you
very rarely failure isn't really an
option it's just a different way you
know I'm gonna say I've never told
anybody this
years ago when I was married and this
was in the 90s like or in the early kind
of when things started to happen and I
told Ann that I was scared wow and I
never told her I was scared and she's
like what are you scared of and I said
not being good enough
yeah and I'd never [__] said I mean
come on look at the way it sounds I've
never had said it I had never said that
to any anybody because this says the
wave was kind of started yeah I mean
it's that imposter syndrome I'm like
have I just tricked all these people
what if I don't what because you saw a
lot of guys go and come back yeah like
you saw a bunch of guys at the club they
go you got that's why I that's why I
don't wear [__] that has comedy club
logos or any comedy logos on it because
these [__] would put jackets on
from evenings improv and Laugh Factory
like oh are you a comedian it's like how
can you [__] tell it motherfucker's
not all the shows like I let my [__]
speak for itself right I don't need to
be putting on a [__] jacket and go on
stage with a [__] hat and all that
[__] and it was the only it was the only
time I said it and the only person I
said it too so I was sick the only time
in modern time that I can think of off
top of my head that I was nervous yeah I
was and I even tried to get out of it
was going to his golf tournament really
oh I told you I told you when I got
there I I called I text you I said hey
you know maybe I don't I shouldn't yeah
I didn't want to go because I'm not used
to I'm familiar because it was
unfamiliar to me yeah even though you
did what you did and you went you know
you you when were you who you were with
it's different it's a place you're not
familiar with and I didn't want to you
know he is a major celebrity yeah I'm
not there to hang on to his belt loop
you know you got other things you're not
in prison so I just wanted to I just hey
you go you know it's all right and then
I'm reading this [__] and I'm a
simple-minded everyday guy from the
street and I'm looking I'm in the club
and it tells you you know you got a word
this kind of clothes this kind of cool
yeah and I'm saying [__] what am
I doing here and so then I talk to him I
said you know I really don't feel
comfortable going George maybe you you
go you're gonna end I don't feel like
and he said no I want you to come he
says people do want to see you so I said
okay and I was still nervous and I told
him that day I see out of your comfort
zone yeah I was more nervous going that
day
than anything in modern time and I told
the wife when I left hey you know what I
I'm more nervous going to this than
anything I've done in in years and it
was something as simple as just going
not just but going to yeah Celebrity
Golf but I mean it's it's in your
essentially and how was it yeah how was
it
now yeah he's like no but you you almost
made me not hate cops
D.L Hughley I'll never forget him he he
came up to me and you said I said hi how
you doing he says good he says you know
what he says uh I got to tell you
something right now what's that he says
I don't like cops and I said okay yeah
and he said you go I've met a few I
didn't like and I just said yeah okay
and he said no no really he says he said
I'll be honest with you he says I hate
most [__] cops and I said okay yeah
that that's all right that that's you
sure and he says but you're different
he says you're not like any other cop
I've ever met
Anne then he says and then George tell
me he says I listen to every podcast you
know that George does he says and George
tells me you've never done this stuff
before and I said no no it's just yeah
and he says well
you're good you and George have good
chemistry keep it up God bless you and
it was just really nice you know to hear
and all day long on the golf course he
kept an eye on me wanted me to make sure
to hydrate because I wouldn't yeah
hydrate because George the celebrity
that he is had the only [__] Golf
Course golf cart without a roof on it so
we're out exposed to the elements all
day I'll always do that to yourself and
so melanoma she's chingon and so we did
it it was a great time so you did have a
good time
the first one was D.L Hughley uh Cedric
the Entertainer and Joe Pesci that's a
damn and oh it was it was a great day
for me uh I got to see Adrian Gonzalez
who was there playing for the Dodgers I
saw from the red tees no yeah you almost
didn't go pardon me you almost almost
didn't go yeah and I almost didn't but
I've done that I've done that a lot you
you don't do that you're not married
though are you no no no no but I've had
plenty of times where I'm like I don't
want to do this but you know what you
reminded me of my favorite movie my
favorite line in all of movies ever is
Rocky one
when he he goes out first of all
that
is my favorite movie of all it's my
favorite line and in any movie I've ever
seen in my entire life he goes out
walking around well first of all he goes
into this he goes into you start crying
he goes in the arena and he goes hey
it's uh it's short it's short to runs
it's white with red not red with white
and that guy looks at him with that
cigar and he goes
doesn't really matter though does it
just give us a good show and in that
moment Rocky realizes like oh I'm all
I'm gonna do is lose and so he walks
around and he comes home and Adrian's
sleeping in bed right and their little
Shack they got right and he's sleeping
there and she wakes up and she says what
is it and he says again beat him
she goes Apollo because yeah I've been
walking around
and I can't beat him
and the things she says back is my
favorite line of the history of all
movies she goes
what are we gonna do
not what are you gonna do not what's
your problem she is in this with him as
much as he's in it and whether it's a
career or a golf cart or or what we're
doing when you don't know how it's going
to go and at any moment you're waiting
for somebody in comedy to fire you and
she says what are we gonna do and and I
was at a place in my life when that
scene really hit me where I was like
that is what you need and your friends
that is what you need in your partner
that when you say hey I don't think I'm
gonna do it they don't go well who cares
I'll let it go it probably wasn't for
you they go what are we gonna do and he
just says oh if I can just go the
distance you know I'm not I won't be I
won't just be a bum off the streets but
it's like that thing when you're like I
think I'm I think I'm afraid right now
and that person's saying to you
what are we going to do it's my favorite
line and you made me think of it when
you said I said I was afraid yeah what
are we gonna do what a perfect
wow she thinks of them as a team as a
unit it's not just him out there in that
ring it's her too which is why he
screams her name so yeah you know I mean
that's another movie but wow I worked
security for that movie and uh when they
did the fight scenes over at the old
Sports Arena
I remember I got [__] Sports Arena
was [__] great man I got an
autographed picture from Apollo Crete
you signed an autograph yeah so I could
take it home to my wife
uh Rocky Sylvester Stallone who's really
a nice guy yeah is it the first one yeah
uh really nice guy
apologized to me because he had run out
of if he says come back he says get you
another one so come back tomorrow I
should have some more yeah
so uh
he didn't have one so I'll tell you what
he sounds dude I took it home and I told
the old wait I said here look I got you
an autograph picture she's oh good and I
gave it to her and it's Apollo creatures
where's the one from Rocky I don't want
this one where's the one from Rock I
want to see where you dirty [__] I mean
Jesus Christ I give you something and
she wasn't satisfied
man did you do a lot of movies
uh it was overtime you know yeah I know
probably free you know I I did a couple
of Rockies I did uh I don't know
something called Boulevard Nights okay
yeah Whittier Boulevard yeah yeah and
that that was it for secure I don't
think I did anything else security wise
then I did some Consulting on other
movies so you know the the one Robert De
Niro and heat you did heat yeah did heat
uh I was in the end of watch uh which is
a great I love end of watching oh it's a
good movie it's a great it's a great I
have I made The Cutting Room floor I've
written a cop show called I'm not
pitching a t but it's it's called code
seven right yeah yeah so it's code set
which is the code for lunch yeah so my
friends who are cops in South Central I
hung out with them a lot and I was a I
was a door guy uh in downtown L.A for
like six years so they would comment did
they'd go to like Taco King and get
stuff and hang out with me and they know
and I would and and so I love these guys
to death uh they're both great cops even
better people and um we were talking
about it might have been in a watch I
love it and it was an inspiration
because they were like 90 of what we do
is paper it's Barney Miller it's
paperwork and it's talking to each other
or it's standing there being like sorry
this is closed you guys just got to keep
going and so I wrote a a cop show that's
built around just that part of the like
what I loved about End of Watch driving
around you're going to do that can't see
me I'm not going to your [__] your
cousin's cousins like all that [__] of
just that chemistry that they had
talking about their families and driving
around so I built a show that was based
just around everything in between like
two cops waiting for the [__] coroner
to come and what do they talk about like
it might have a scene where they talk
about can you believe people are still
afraid of escalators we've had escalate
and it's that sort of mundane
conversation I was like I want a cop
show that's like that where stuff still
happened they got a job to do but so
much of it is just the relationship
which was so real so good yeah probably
one of the best cop movies ever I love
it did you know that they really drove
they real that's real that's a real
accident were you there that day no that
breaks the brakes didn't work when
they're chasing that at night right
before they run into the building they
slam into the back of that van that was
all real and now not playing oh wow yeah
they they couldn't stop so they just
they just kept rolling the director on
that was from David Ayers right David he
was from South L.A oh okay yeah he was
he was a good guy they wanted to do some
fight scenes they cut out all the fight
scenes boxing matches because I used to
do a ring announcing well they do that
one where he fights like before he
fights the guy into the market yeah I
had I had an old partner that did that I
said hey I said they're not going to
believe this I said there's a guy that
actually tooks in the movie takes off
his badge and his belt and gets in the
fight and I started laughing because he
did that no [__] yeah he did that on it
there's some stuff on YouTube where in
South Central the guy goes [__] you
want to go head up and the [__] cop
takes this thing off and they [__]
throw man yeah one up [__] one-on-one
earn the respect right there if you got
it crazy so they were gonna do some
boxing scenes yeah yeah and I used to be
a ring announcer so they the guy that
was technically one of the tech told
David Ayers hey I got a guy that did
that for the Department between LLP and
the Sheriff's Department
and he said
see if he wants to do it so they they
called I said sure I'll do it so they
gave me the script
and then he said okay come down I want
to talk to you so I went down the inter
interview with David Ayers and he says
what'd you think I said well I I saw the
script I cried and I laughed I said
great great [__] anyway the way it
ends yeah and he said you up and I said
I'm up he said okay let's do it and so I
did it the night that they're showing
the premiere yeah the producer comes up
and I'm with my wife and he says Hey
Gill he says I may as well tell you
right now don't be looking for yourself
on the screen he says we cut out seven
minutes of boxing and they were going to
show how the Mexican gets to fight the
black egg this is why he knows how to
fight but it came out so good he said we
cut that out at least you didn't find
out in your seat yeah but I am I'm in
the credits special thanks to gilk real
and if you bought the DVD the outtakes
I'm in there oh really yes oh I'm gonna
I'll I'll find it just to watch five
people [__] oh so uh
I did uh tax collector I got directed by
David Aaron oh really I know David he's
a good guy
it's all dudes yeah a little bit Slinky
like you like that yeah
a gringo in South Central from Navarro
that's all we talked that's how we just
talk you know that [__] can
throw man really tall dude there's a
scene in that movie can I ask you if
this is real they're sitting there I
think it's I think uh Jake Gyllenhaal's
driving and these uh gang bangers they
approached the car and he just pulls and
holds it like right up to the door yeah
is that a move would someone potentially
do that sure he just had it he's just
chilling talking to him and he's he's
already got it like all the time because
he doesn't know why this guy's walking
up all the time I've always wondered
about that move because I was like
that's either completely made up like no
one person thought of that or this
happens every day maybe it was about all
real [__] he was like I'm sure those
dudes they're realistic that's why those
guys knew if they hit the back of that
[__] band don't be like cut
an actor can't say cut no no no and
sometimes I get mad if they say cut too
soon like I was like no no I'm good I'm
good man
what they do they call it the table read
yeah yeah okay so come time to do a
table read
and I asked David I said hey do you want
me to say these words like they're
they're in here
and he says well yeah why are you
thinking I said because realities are a
ring announcer wouldn't say this stuff
you know this wouldn't be real you know
you want to get people in the fight you
want to get them he's okay hey say
whatever you want
so everybody's doing their read now it's
time for me to read and I announced uh
the boxers and did what I said you know
here's the guy hailing from the Mean
Streets of East L.A and I gave the guy
his name gave him a name we did it and
when we're as soon as I I did that
get ready the table started clapping so
it went up well I I thought it was gonna
well it was awesome hey
cut that [__] [__]
he looks down here he's like he's like
we'll go now so so okay enough about us
sorry
um
how did how did you you did you go
Second City that I started working at
Second City yeah it's just a night host
like I was just making nachos and
restocking the bar and stuff like that
and just watching everybody on stage and
I was like I can't wait to do that I
mean people like Tim Robinson who has a
show on Netflix and Sam Richardson Brad
Morris and you know Second City like
they're comedians but also
some of the [__] best
actors that you will see have gone to
Second City like you'll see an actress
and you'll be like uh oh look look her
up and you'll be their second City and
and for comedy but also drama but just
overall presence acting in Chicago did I
not hear you yeah I remember yourself
here or Outback Chicago oh back I loved
it man that place saved my life yeah
yeah I was just such a down I didn't
have anything I didn't have a place I
was living and that just and I wanted to
be here but it kept me Chicago is such a
real city city like you can very easily
get distracted like I'm not really doing
that you know there's you've got to keep
yourself really ingratiated whether it's
the stand-up scene or The Improv scene
and so it it carried me all the way
through until I moved out here and sorry
so so so you were over there and did you
where did you do stand up at I didn't do
it until I got here oh [__] yeah I came
out here and started in UCB and that's
how I met the slaw Brothers uh dudes we
love Scarborough we started doing a
podcast with them and then how many
years is that not like recently oh no
well dumb people town uh 2017 but we
were doing a different version of it
years before that and um
I you know we would take dumb news
stories and then just sit around and I
didn't know because I was so new this is
essentially what in writer's rooms yeah
before so did you see the thing last
night with the and then everybody will
joke around for about 10 minutes and
then somebody probably you will go all
right guys we got to get to work right
and so
I was doing that every week and and they
said um
they said uh you should be doing
stand-up you got takes on everything we
talk about you do characters I I do this
like for when I first started I did this
Mark Wahlberg character yeah and I would
do that I just talk like this all the
time I'm like how you doing you're doing
good what's going on you guys should
have Donnie in here sometime help me
straighten them out so like uh and I
would and I would do like that character
and so they were like hey who does that
thing yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and I
would do it uh and they said hey we're
doing Comedy on State you're gonna
feature and so I did I uh I did 20
minutes and I did some character stuff I
did a lot of stuff I would never do
again how did you end up doing the Mark
Wahlberg though uh Second City was
goofing around with some of those people
there and then people told the scars
about it and they were doing a thing
where they would do like character
voicemails or you know have someone do
an Impressions and so they heard mine
and we were already starting to work
together and they were like let's let's
put that in the episode yeah and it just
kind of like I ended up doing that you
remember you ever do set list where you
like make it up because Paul provenza's
show you make it up as you go they give
you
and I would do that as Mark Wahlberg and
then Doug Benson would be like hey come
on my show and just be him the whole
time and so I would do it what's he
famous for what are his lines who marks
oh yeah oh my God I mean
I mean what are you doing what are you
what are you I would talk about it I
mean I'll talk about anything you want
we could sit here we could sit here for
the next five [__] minutes dude I'll
talk to you about doing five case I do a
5k Every Day you don't do a 5k dude I
sleep with belt with dumbbells in my
hands so when I get up
and I would just do the whole character
and and just goofy you know these dudes
matter like that's yeah that
[__] plays golf he's done in
[__] 45 minutes oh he's he breathing
suit you're like what the funny thing
about a Mark Wahlberg impression is and
Paramount wanted us to do a thing for
Transformers and Mark was like I think
it's funny I appreciate it I just I
don't have the time right but his acting
voice is way up here I'll talk like this
all day dude you see me new in that Ted
movie yeah that player didn't even talk
the whole time we were on set they did
that in post
um but they but his right his talking
voice is down here I don't know dude you
wanna you wanna play golf tomorrow you
want to play some golf I'm probably
gonna go out I don't know probably like
around I see I get up at 3 30 a.m I get
a workout in by four so maybe like five
a.m 5 AM you wanna go to like it's a
when they were in Boston on the [__]
River with a [__] bear and everybody
said okay
everybody's [__] down that's it some
of his best lines are are not are from
we needed to fight him [__] hilarious
bro oh yeah yeah not not you not you not
you it's my time it's my time now I'm
the one to shine and then Christian Bale
runs around on cocaine for two hours and
wins an ostrich but uh yeah so I did
that and then I went on stage and and
did 20 minutes I did I did Mark Wahlberg
I did some other character stuff I had
one bit that I did that and I had never
done before that ended up on my first
album and um it's just as you know man
I'm preaching to the preacher of the
choir but but just do instead it was
just the most pure but I was afraid if
you want to talk about being for a long
time I I started a little bit late I
didn't start till I was like in my early
30s so so I I kind of you kind of need
to be really young but you know man when
you [__] start at any age I agree you
feel like
you are
a [__] grain of sand nobody gives a
[__] about you you can help you yeah
what time is it like just you know it's
[__] nothing right put your name
right there whatever you've been here
before you know right just [__]
everything is dismissive for [__]
years for years for years but the good
thing about if starting really young is
good because you're too dumb yet to know
how bad you are when you're older and
you get some life in you even if you're
not good at comedy you know you can you
know when it's bad and so that was kind
of the fear for me is like I was like I
know how bad I'm gonna be but but the
the scars and other friends of mine
they're just like duh dude you're funny
go for it and so so you almost have a
little bit of like a minor league yeah
well because by the time yes with the
podcast and UCB and Second City and all
that stuff I I had was very comfortable
on stage finding the joke telling the
joke being performing it was just about
that like this is just your material
this is your thought this is your
perspective and um I poured myself in
there that was 2015 and I it's you know
I mean yeah doing stand-ups it's just
the most purest form of and even in your
show right you're Translating that
comedy that perspective into a camera
form and to to relate it in another way
but the most distilled version dude is
you with one [__] microphone being
like you know what I [__] and then
but also I knew for the stand-up part of
it first of all I knew that everybody
thought that comedians couldn't act
because you really can't right you know
because you if you're not trained oh
some of our friends are the worst and
then you know there's some guys that I
didn't you know I think the mistake that
standards make is they think that they
it's just an easy transition I'd be
ignorant to think that you could just
become a police officer and then be a
detective like it's it's police work no
it's not right you go from there and
then I knew that I needed to get a
[__] acting coach like [__] the
first day I read in front of my partners
I was like I get a [__] coach got a
great coach she was with me 102 shows if
I didn't hire her I don't see I don't
see the [__] fall of 2002 how about
right
and nobody expected so smart but I did
it you know I did it so smart
and I and and you have to say
I know
in I'm gonna get an acting coach you
know no no I do right like I know right
I know I need a [__] acting coach
right and well people ask Seinfeld how
come you don't do more acting just
because I can't you can't act he's like
that show was built around me
essentially doing my stand-up in
conversation ideas that Larry David or I
had he goes I'm not an actor
yeah but he's like I can't act and he
said it he's like I don't I don't I have
no idea what I'm doing but you know a
lot of comics too I learned this uh from
another comic they were like well a lot
of comics the reason you don't see them
do other stuff isn't some don't want to
some just love the stage but some of
them can't write in other people's
voices so they can't they don't go on to
like write on TV shows and other stuff
because they can only write in their
voice from their point of view which is
a whole other muscle and a skill and
there are obviously inherently people
that are just no matter where you put
them they're going to be funny so the
first show I went in there me Bruce and
rubber went in there like August to like
the end of September October and we had
the pilot and then the pot script was
really good and then Warner Brothers
wasn't in
the habit of making a comedian a Creator
because Creator you make money because
you're going to get a percentage of the
points yeah or I wasn't an executive
producer until like the first three
three years so
Bruce went to Peter Roth who was the
head of TV and said you got to make this
guy a Creator because
it's not anything that I can do he's
doing it all all we're doing is
listening he's going in there he's
telling all his stories to write it down
it's got nothing to do with us it's all
him yeah and they did I got it
and this one
and in this one I mean
that's such a [__] crap shoot anyways
man of like you know getting you we were
here the whole time getting an idea
going and getting the got pilot you got
one and I would tell everybody we just
got one don't worry about it was it the
international 13 and then back nine no
it's all different one one twelve which
is 13. yeah yeah and then NBC because
they saw what the numbers
were and are that they did a 22 episode
season which is very back in the 70s
yeah [__] so they're going to start
with shows you believe in they'll do 22
Episodes and that's
that's [__] you made it yeah like
this Show's a [__] hit man like I
don't even look I don't really look at
the no I don't look at anything I just
wait I'm going to New York tomorrow go
do Seth Meyers in the view and Sherry
Shepherd like in just a couple of two
days and it's like I know what it is
because I already can feel what it is
from the first time like I don't need to
go look at a number I can't feel I can
feel what it is yeah and even even
though it's good for your daughter
though too to have that perspective yes
and she's like and my mind's like I
can't believe I get to make this trip
with you and you saw you saw me there
I'm just I'm just an actor man I go I
don't flex I just do my thing man and
keep everybody together that's my I know
what it is I've been there I gotta keep
everybody together everybody happy is
there an issue we replace a couple of
people that I didn't have a problem with
but they had issues with and if the lady
is uncomfortable but is that the value
comfortable make some changes before
your first show had you been number one
on the call sheet never it's a it's a
weird thing I did a feature and it's a
different like you're saying it's a
different feeling than any it all kind
of like trickles down it's all about
what it starts what's our attitude on
set today what's our attitude about
doing another take like it's you're
really the quarterback like the every
play has to go through you first that's
interesting that you hadn't done that
before your first show that's a huge
number one man [__] I mean yeah it's a I
mean I know it's a little inside
baseball but for but they go you know
I'm walking with number one I got number
one we're walking it's a trip man it's
crazy because even the first one was
like I can see I was at the doctor today
and then the thing you can see it in
there that the one the boxing episode
Laila Ali and I saw Laila Ali at Dancing
with the Stars and I told her hey come
and do my show I'd love to so we created
that thing and then when we were doing
her father and then she she's in the gym
we did this gym and I hadn't done all
these voice and then she's like Hey kid
you're good you got to keep your right
up and he's like oh thanks but I will
take advice from women and I say hey Max
this is this is
and she was like in the rehearsal she
was like
yeah wow
she goes whoa whoa and I go watch she
goes oh my God
did you wait you did it in rehearsal
yeah yeah did you think about saving it
for tape I it worked we were close
because she was only there that okay oh
okay I think yeah yeah and the in the
like the day and then the yeah and uh
she lost it she [__] lost it that's
correct and she goes that's my father
like the father I know but see that's
you setting the tone on set keeping it
Loose I never told her I'd do I never
told her I did it yeah
that's great he's like I'll take him
it's just there
it's air like halfway say like you come
home [__] 3 30 in the morning they'd
be like what the [__] I was out there
oh I can't do that I can't do it that's
a good voice I was so pretty I was so
funny
right that is usually I don't even do
my thank God
I don't really [__] do uh but I mean
if you could you know I was doing oh man
this is this is great you know I was
doing the I think I was doing Sherry the
Sherry Shepard pre-interview and they
said
did mine grow up being fussed mine was
funny on their own she wasn't funny for
me it's just funny from and she goes I
said mine didn't see me do stand up till
I was she was 19. I was curious about
myself I sold out the United Center in
Chicago me said and DL Eddie yeah and uh
[__] money came in the dressing room
with her friends and she opens I could
still see open the door she goes now I
know why mommy didn't want me to see you
and I go why and she goes because
you can fly yeah like you can fly yeah
she she just she wanted you to stay her
dad she
like and and wanted to keep me on a
level right to where she didn't see that
right so I'm saying she's just that
you're just dead you're just no I think
I think for for the equivalent of oh
part of it yeah okay
yes yeah it would almost be like if she
was on Broadway and I wasn't right then
you go see because oh my God your mom is
incredible right thank you yeah so she's
like [__] and she knew it was I mean she
might have said it was the language but
not so much that's really she just
wanted to keep us as parents and then
when I still remember the door opened
and she's like now I know because you
can fly and I thought yeah what a great
thing to hear you're flying and that's
why when somebody says you know how long
do you think you'll do stand-ups I don't
know but if you could fly into your 60s
wouldn't you look at new heart would
would I know would uh uh [__] [__]
Bob Newhart you know the crowd was a
little bit so stubborn when he redid it
and I think he laid down [__] the one
time you do the [__] Tonight Show and
that [__] lays down
and he didn't do his great and even he
even said during the first part of the
[__] interview he told Johnny you
want you want me to leave and come back
again that might be good
and that was my first [__] Tonight
Show spot I saw him in a town he got out
of the elevator and I said I said hey
hey Bobby George oh hey George [__]
old [__] I said hey we did The
Tonight Show together he goes yeah that
crowd was like so so hot [__]
you made him so so
oh me and Johnny and Johnny comes out
the night before this is your first time
first time my only time on the with him
with him and [__] the night I watched
the night before and they were [__]
horrible this this is uh my elders and
we got a young man here today and and
and then when he starts the crowd is so
good he says in the monologue this is
way better than last night and then
[__] Bob Newhart goes out there
[__]
and he's like we have a young man making
his first [__] that crowd was like
you're gonna love this guy
yeah this was his Rolex rare really yeah
how do you remember that I got a
question somebody wrote me a message
what kind of Rolex is that it is a can I
see it it is a [__] 24 karat gold
presidential
uh bezel engraved Rolex Presidential
league president it's a presidential
okay he asked me what what so in 79 when
his Alexis his wife got it Alex is right
his wife got it for him
um nobody was wearing Rolexes in 79 not
really that's amazing it's very European
yeah
this came to me from a jeweler that we
know that my worker person knows and uh
when I [__] held this [__]
for the first time you can feel it it
went through me man yeah and when I did
it and he shook my hand he was wearing
this watch how many times have you told
the story of how you got Carson
I don't want to make you tell if you
told 100 times I'll go listen to
whatever you want me to do it did it
take a while the last time
how you how you got the Watcher how you
got it Carson you know Ron shock got I
think Ron shock is passed uh uh
I saw in 90
. any kid under any kid under 25 30
right now will never know what it means
to have gone in person let me tell you
man
I might have been in Las Vegas working
at the at Harrah's I pick up a USA Today
every day Ron shock was there Johnny had
just announced he was leaving in the
next year yeah and they said 83
91. okay he was leaving in May of night
summer of 91. okay he was leaving in May
of 92. gotcha I read that thing in June
I'm nowhere near La I'm on the [__]
road
I read it has Ron shocked in the
lifestyle thing he's one of
six more spots
I'm sitting in a [__] hotel room I'm
reading it and I go wow man it's like
[__] Willy Wonka
[__] Match six six golden tickets in
a year never thinking that I would be
one right and then and now you know the
Factory's close
man
and it's leaving yeah never thought and
I go back to LA and Shapiro West have
Seinfeld George Wallace you know if
they're looking at me and then Jim
McCauley members only jacket comes in
there I'm at The Improv I'm Melrose I'm
Melrose he comes in I'm doing so so not
my favorite actually probably my least
favorite room getting some labs and he's
standing next to them and they know him
because of Jerry and everything and
McCauley goes you represent this guy and
he's like we're thinking about it oh
well Tom you know if you do tell them
that you know I want to see some more
tell me call the office and things like
that so I go I get off stage and both of
them God Rest their soldiers did you see
him walk in when you were on stage okay
good thank God and uh they say they say
good news we got to potentially may have
gotten you The Tonight Show they didn't
[__] give me [__] right standing
right next to you that's them that's
their angle that's their angle so I go
to NBC go through the Tonight Show thing
go through the hallway Johnny's in his
room the [__] filming I go in there
upstairs and he's like what do you got
from I said let me see some stuff I'll
go in there
due to about 10 minutes and he's like
didn't laugh and he's like just you but
this isn't even a show in front of the
in front you're him and I'm in front of
the desk oh what a [__] horrible way
to do he's like he might go
silent when I'm done he goes okay
lose the beginning take the middle
movement to the front the beginning I
don't like take it out tighten it and
let and come back and call me when
you're ready for me to see you so I'm
living in a condo on Barham
uh mine is not I don't think I'm married
I'm not even married I'm living with
that and um
I work on it every day for [__] 12
hours I fall asleep on the coffee table
wake up and [__] and none of it fits
in the secrets but I make it fit right
and then I go the next two weeks later I
go to the Improv 10 days later
and I'm only there to work out we're
we're Adam where did you like to work in
town
um where did you like to go the ice
house and the Laugh Factory they're
about to come back and uh yeah yeah and
then uh my and then um
I see him walking I'm like oh [__]
yeah and he walks in and he walks
straight over to he goes oh are you
going up I said yeah he goes are you
doing any of the stuff uh for the show
and I said in the beginning maybe in the
beginning yeah he goes oh I'll check it
out
[__]
I wouldn't I didn't call him he just
happened to be there of course he
happened to be that that's all he did
yeah
I go up there
and I'm just get on I ride the [__]
wave of the person before me
and I get in the hallway and he goes
congratulations young man you just got
yourself The Tonight Show no that was
Johnny that went to visit that was
called Jim McCauley
wait he said that to you do you remember
right where you were standing in the
Empire of course you [__] do right by
the two right by the right before you
exit the two doors and he shook your
[__] hand and sent it to you
congratulations young man there's very
we just got yourself The Tonight Show so
few times in an entertainment career
where you can feel the page turn where
it had because someone's it's so gradual
right like you you you think of a pilot
you ride the pilot you pitch the pile
hey maybe we'll shoot it right oh made
the might shoot it oh they're gonna
shoot it hey maybe we'll get an order
you get her and by the time things
happen it's taken so long and gone
through so much stuff it kind of feels
like well it better [__] happen we've
been waiting for this right but moments
like that whether it's an Oscar or an
award whatever it is especially for us
Carson and they go congrats you can feel
so everything's different after this
moment so then
I'm booked
in no November of 91 on a Wednesday
they call Monday afternoon and they say
uh Bill Cosby wants to do Wednesday and
Bill Cosby doesn't want
two comedian we don't want two comedians
on the show he wants to do stand-ups
sure this [__] man I just want
to try to get some I mean the stories of
him the stories of him [__] people
over never end
foreign
and then everybody that I talked is like
all the community is like yo man I have
a friend of mine that got bumped that
[__] never got called back again
yeah you're like yeah yeah I get it I
know [__] man I'm like man there's no I
don't have no control over it right and
then they call
when so take Monday Tuesday Wednesday
the day I was going to be on McCauley
College goes next Wednesday okay uh
November 21st 1991.
and uh and that was that was the [__]
okay oh my God I love that [__] [__]
this is my Goosebumps I like catching a
Peeping Tom over here I [__] did it
man I did it I watched [__] I watched it
growing up I watched it growing up
I watched all my favorites this watch
from 79 to he wore this watch his last
show this watch hogged Bette Midler and
all that and all of it wow and the and
the second [__] most beautiful you
know like you start to meet people you
never like Robert you know Whoopi Robin
Williams yeah yeah yeah and then in 2005
they had like six whole I remember only
been around 2002 three four two three
four five okay there's like six seven
hosts of the Emmys right Garrett Conan
me Ray Wanda Sykes and I presented the
first Emmy for reality TV and [__]
live the Emmys
[__] look good slim down thing [__]
it and I'm [__] scared to death man
and
we're waiting to come back from
commercials live I look around the
corner and [__] Robin Williams is
sitting
front and center in the Middle with near
The Sopranos of willing Grace and
[__] Edward Loves Raymond every Six
Feet Under
and Robin Williams sees me and he goes
like this
[__] [__] one like he went
like this he went because you're on the
same team and [__] that's all I
needed man yeah I didn't look to see
Robin Williams I looked to just see the
people yeah yeah yeah but you got to see
and that [__] saw he of course
he's a comedian right that's what I'm
saying he he's looking he was already
looking yeah I went out there anymore
like that
you're like [__] and I was good go
get him yeah he was very cool to
remember he was oh that's amazing man I
met him once he was amazing that's the
[__] like you know nobody sees that
right talk about it but [__] the best
man right oh I love that [__] well I'm
glad that I'm glad what are you doing
now like you have a special you have a
special and all that [__] right I'm just
I'm just working
um I just ended my last tour at the end
of last year and then uh Rory Scoville
and I great comic we have a podcast
called pen pals where people send their
letters in and we read we read their
letters some are advice but some are
just like hey how [__] we can't get
[__] Aaron to figure out how to
listen to [__] phone messages they're
giving us a [__] imaginary [__] oh
my God if you guys did an episode once a
month where you let people you read a
letter or an email someone sent it I
guess that's all you need right there so
uh [__] Jersey comes with some
[__] stipulation we should have you
guys on pen pals and then you can see
how we do it but we just get letters
people about anything in their life what
do you think of my new haircut should I
break up with my boyfriend whatever it
is
um that's called pen pals at drop server
weeks and then the scalar brothers and I
have taken our show dumb people town
right here to All Things comedy Aaron's
running the show for us oh hey
yeah it is
um and that drops every single Tuesday
and obviously we would love to have you
guys on that show yeah but other than
I'd love to other than that yeah just be
like the [__]
dude oh you
you have time I'm sure yeah but you know
what you know the thing with Gill is
that is that uh like did they ask you to
retire how did you end up retiring no I
ended up retiring on my own I was 60
years old and you know man it's like
this [__] is more useful now
yeah they like they may you know you
retire and then all of a sudden like
all of a sudden you it's everything and
then it's not like when the show ends it
it's [__] hard on the person that the
show is about your career like you know
I love the first show
but when it ended I'm I'm the
[__] that took all the because
my name yeah of course all the other
actors could go do [__] uh switch
that birth or whatever the [__] they're
doing and I'm the name so I take the
[__] Heat and
it goes from
every it just goes from color to [__]
back to black and white yeah essentially
because it changes quick isn't that I
was in that house right there I'm
talking to Peter Roth and I'm like he's
[__] beating around the bush and I'm
like it's like May 17th of 2007 I said
are we done
because he was just [__] circles I
said hey are we done
he goes we're done yeah and I said all
right
but you missed I mean and I hung up and
I said what am I going to do now right I
[__] everything see that's why don't
you ever just want to work a case again
I heard I was listening to the Time
episode the one of the more recent ones
you guys had and you were talking about
the Utah case and we've said enough oh
we don't do that on the road but but do
you ever get the like I'd love to work
oh yes yes cases come up I wish I were
you ever get pulled into consult or
somebody to take a look people ask me
you know I got to go back on the TDK
time buying them yeah BTK BTK that's a
[__] respect BTK Dennis Raider
[__] Dennis Raiders
he said the [__] disc and he goes hey
is there any way that you guys can uh
track where cable no not at all sir they
[__] said they go that was a [__]
the church ptk I went down and I get
called uh but
there are new investigators out there
yeah that are better than anything
they're they're working they're doing
their job they're good
time in life for me okay it's probably
the best time in life that's great too
do you go
let's talk about
let's go back let's use a rocky as an
analogy
do you go Drago the training all the
machines or do you go the guy that's
carrying the [__] log on his back up
the mountain you know the [__] hat
boots on the ground left in that wagon
on the ground versus the [__]
that has all the electrons like police
work is still very much like talk to the
people knock on the doors walk them when
I got there they said three s's you want
to be successful
snitches shoe leather Scotch really
that's what will solve cases for you wow
I never did learn never did Acquire The
Taste for Scotch yeah I thought it was
pppb what was it was it what is the sssb
what is it Scott snitches
[Laughter]
quick Carson's story really quick just
about being out yeah
um I was listening to this guy who's
talking about he came into the Simpsons
like after he retired in like oh Carson
did 99 something like that it was years
after he's been done and he oh my God
like stepped into the they had gotten
done right they'd kind of gone over the
scripture with the writers and
everything and after like 10 15 minutes
they kind of looked around he wasn't
leaving
and he just kind of likes and they
thought you know it's Carson you're
going to get 10 minutes and he's you're
gonna get you're gonna get him on it and
somebody finally after he goes was like
he missed it
he missed being in a room with other
Comedians and writers breaking down how
how things gonna go what the bit is here
what we're gonna do and it was some of
that like we're talking about listen
when you lose it when it goes to when it
goes to black and white and he got a
chance for a day to kind of go back into
the color a little bit and he missed it
I'm gonna tell you that Helen kushnick
and whatever the dude's name is that
floated that story that John is retiring
that Jay Leno was part of Jay Leno is
part of this whole conspiracy to remove
Johnny Carson before Johnny Carson was
going to retire so you know respectful
to whoever was affected by it Conan
Letterman channeling got arrested Soul
me uh Jay Leno is a [__] Pariah as
far as comedians are concerned because
of Helen kushnick and the fact that she
said to him you'll eat the meat but you
don't want to know how the [__] cow
is killed right he was he was complicit
in all of it I've never worked he's got
another face that wasn't burnt but not
my favorite not camel's favorite not
Conan's favorite not Howard Stern's
favorite right like
I'm I'm in I'm in a club of of a select
few that can all agree on one thing
we're not fans of that guy and you know
what that's who that guy is and that's
that's why
well they said you went at 10 o'clock
and [__] everything I mean go away you
don't go alone Conan's been so great to
me that I'm obviously that's you know
but phone is awesome man and it's Jay
Leno not being able to go away which
cost me my late night position and Jay
Leno's 10 o'clock you know but if you
get removed from The Tonight Show and
NBC as well that means you should not
have given him a 10 o'clock show it's
like why eat before you eat right like
you're watching this dude you should
have just taken his Hit And Gone Away
how would he how would Jay Leno have
liked it if Johnny Carson went at
[__] 10 and he went at 11 30. same
thing right yeah well they said that one
day that's a pretty good runoff they
said that one day they could feel Carson
just kind of he just missed it hey man
you're gonna you're gonna [__] miss
it yeah and you know
he was always
he was always very
Dapper and when it was over man he he
declined man yeah he was heavier it
wasn't doing as much stuff he'd go to
Wimbledon you know yeah I enjoy now I I
lecture all over the place sure and and
he's going to take a first-class airfare
you know back to New York to do the
television I'm driving all the way to
Temecula to do wine and crime at a at a
point same amount of time yeah so it it
it's good I enjoy going out and speaking
I enjoy but listen but there's nothing
nothing better than me getting with the
guys from homicide yeah yeah yeah let's
go out and have lunch let's go out and
have a drink getting where they got
that's back in the business yeah that's
what this other stuff is fun yeah that's
this that's sitting around the table so
that keeps me into business that's oh
man and we get talk cases and you know
what um oh
oh man what happened bomb
Jay Leno's calling you
[Laughter]
oh no no Seinfeld no
hey so this won't go on right Seinfeld
says I can act so that
oh [__] oh [__] all right well hey man
thank you sorry hey before we go hey
don't say it like that hey before we go
I got I got I gotta get this out here
and let me let me go I got a shout out I
just go ahead because that was a [__]
[__] I just want to say I had
the privilege the honor of visiting
there was an academy class from the
sheriff's department two months ago
there was a vehicle that ran into the
class run over by people yeah okay I got
to visit I had the honor and the
privilege of being uh present with
uh Lauren preciado the female that was
in critical condition at one time and
her partner who's in the room next to
her Jose Adias they're both doing well
shout out to them don't give up I've got
a future ahead of you God bless you
thank you
hey take a picture right here and then
we'll get the [__] out of here yeah good
shout out hey come on
no come on let's do it right here man
come on listen
we're going to lower the number sorry I
talked so much yeah
that's awesome